but because my brother died that way i
want
justice
and i want to have a little peace in my
grief
a father shot and killed while leaving
work now our i-team with the new video
police say could crack this case wide
open somebody fired a barrage of bullets
at alfonso turner killing him and a
camera captures two men right before
could they be his killers with tonight's
vegas unsolved here's the i-team's david
charms
the two figures walking on your screen
may have killed 29 year old alfonzo
turner a camera recording the two men
outside the apartment complex where
turner worked less than a minute later
we see turner's final moments alive he's
driving this white car when bullets
start flying you can see them streaking
through the air he had a lot of friends
he didn't have enemies jerica arrington
says her younger brother al as she
called him was funny kind the light of a
big family he was just very humorous and
goofy
very positive turner a father of four
worked a steady job as a security guard
on mountain vista near sahara nellis
he'd go i got kids i ain't got time for
that
so we just coined that phrase i didn't
realize how much i quote him until
i lost him it's may 8th turner is
leaving work a friend in the passenger
seat when those two figures fired at his
car they shot 40 times at this point we
don't have
any viable leads that we're following up
on metro homicide lieutenant ray spencer
says there's a lot of unknowns was
turner the target what's the motive but
what he is sure of is this isn't a
robbery gone bad clearly someone wasn't
trigger shy anytime you have that many
gun shots
is concerning and they may have their
suspects well you can't see their faces
police believe the two figures are men
investigators hope you could help
identify them by how they walk or from
what they're wearing we will find you
and we will find them
and the law will run its course
arrington says investigators have found
no connection with anybody her brother
knew and what happened to him finding
out who those two men are could be the
break investigators need
i want people to come forward because
it's the right thing to do
you can watch the video clips from the
murder scene right now on 8newsnow.com
and inside our app as with all of our
vegas unsolved cases crime stoppers is
offering a reward for any information
leading to an arrest you can leave
anonymous tips by calling them or going
to their website and we have all that
information on our website for you as
well i'm david charns live local now